[Music]
the release of the Last Guardian on ps4
will be the culmination of almost a
decade of development a process that
began all the way back in 2007 that's a
long time to be hearing very little and
seeing even less about a game that is
one of the most anticipated titles this
year or indeed ever so if you want to
find out why the hype is so high for
this white whale of a video game why
team ICO's previous games Shadow of the
Colossus and ICO are consistently cited
as some of the best games of all time
and how an unanticipated player reaction
to a feature in a previous game led for
me to await up to the central concept of
the Last Guardian stay tuned as we take
a look back at the history and legacy of
Team Ico in 1997 Fumito a waiter
joined Sony Computer Entertainment as a
first party game designer having
previously worked on enemy zero on the
Sega Saturn he began working on an
animation to convey the idea for his
first game inspired by elements of
Prince of Persia another world and
lemmings the core idea revolved around a
simple boy-meets-girl story where the
two main characters would form an
emotional bond without communicating
that animation and idea would become the
team's first game and namesake Iko Iko
sometimes pronounced eco tells the story
of ICO a boy born with bullhorns who is
locked away in a stone coffin in an
abandoned fortress when he comes of age
while trying to escape ICO stumbles
across Yoda a young girl in an equally
tragic situation her mother the Queen
intends to sacrifice yatta to extend her
own life Eiko decides to help your to
escape and the two set out together to
find a way out of the fortress
Aiko's gameplay revolves around puzzle
platforming and traversal with the
player directly controlling Eiko
unfortunately Yoda isn't nearly as
mobile or adventurous as Eiko which
showcases echos most iconic gameplay
mechanic by holding r1 players can take
Yoda by the hand and lead her through
obstacles and away from danger
puzzles are never overly difficult or
obtuse but the necessity to help you or
to overcome them serves to strengthen
the emotional bond between the two
likewise combat is a simple one-button
affair that serves only to rescue Yoda
as the game's enemies attempt to kidnap
her and dragged her into shadowy
vortexes Eiko was designed using the
process
of as a waiter himself describes it
subtracting design wherein elements were
removed if they impacted the design
goals of the team this resulted in many
elements that would uniquely distinguish
ICO including a lack of heads-up display
and interface and it's singular shadowy
figure enemy type originally the game
focused on ICO attempting to return the
order to her room in the fortress after
she is kidnapped by horned warriors but
a waiter deemed the warriors to
graphically intensive for the engine so
they were replaced with the final games
shadow creatures after changing release
platforms from the original PlayStation
2 the PlayStation 2 in addition to four
years of development ICO was released in
North America on September 24 2001 the
game was a critical success with
GameSpot's miguel lopez awarding it an
8.5 and concluding ICO serves as a
strong testament to the potential of
video game aesthetics and boldly asserts
that a strong production can indeed a
driver game when it's coupled with solid
play mechanics critical success didn't
translate into commercial success
however with ICO selling less than
300,000 copies in North America as of
2009 these low sales and its sparse
presence at retail helped to create a
cult status around ICO that has
continued to this day
several factors have been blamed for
Aiko's disappointing sales in North
America while Fumito Widow drew the
European and Japanese cover art himself
North American copies were sold with a
generic rushed cover that has been
called the worst video game cover ever
made the American version also liked
several unlockable bonuses including a
two-player mode and translation for
yours dialogue a waiter has also said
that his insistence on subtracting
design may have taken too much out of
the game something he vowed to minimize
on his next project Shadow of the
Colossus
[Music]
Team Ico began work on Shadow of the
Colossus in 2002 under the name Nikko a
way to conceive the game to challenge
the perceived idea of what a video game
boss could be as such 16 colossi are the
only enemies in the game each with a
unique arena and behavioral pattern for
players to overcome Shadow of the
Colossus tells the story of wander a
young man on a quest to resurrect a
young woman travelling with his only
companion a horse named agro wander
enters the Forbidden Land to make a
bargain with an entity known as doorman
doorman is willing to restore the young
woman's life on the condition that
wanted to feat the 16 colossi that
inhabit the Forbidden Land who waiter
and producer Kenji Kido held the team to
an incredibly high standard throughout
production on Shadow of the Colossus a
waiter has stated that he felt only two
out of the 500 artists who applied met
his perfectionist criteria and he would
often demand changes in design to fall
more in line with his vision likewise
Kato a veteran game designer who worked
on the original Ape Escape challenged
the programmers to implement realistic
physics and effects that would shift the
lead characters interaction
realistically in reaction to the colossi
for example if a colossus extended its
arm horizontally Kato insisted that one
to be able to run across the limb as if
he were traversing any other flat
surface the waiter again implemented his
theory of subtraction design across all
elements of the game there are no
enemies outside of the sixteen colossi
and no other life inhabits the Forbidden
Land say for the occasional white or
black tailed lizard while traversing the
flat desolate landscape only the sounds
of wander aggro and the landscape itself
can be heard with the spice use of music
search for emotional or pivotal
narrative moments the lonely hero
atmosphere epic multi-staged colossi
battles and the tragic open-ended story
of Shadow of the Colossus again proved a
critical hit for Team Ico with game
spots Brad shoemaker awarding the game
an eight point seven and surmising
there's never really been anything like
it on the PlayStation 2 or any other
platformer in stark contrast to ICO
Shadow of the Colossus was also a
commercial success selling a hundred and
forty thousand copies in its first week
in Japan almost 80% of which was in the
first two days the game didn't escape
criticism however with many reviewers
struggling with the game's erratic
framerate and camera controls a grow
also proved divisive as a waiter
intentionally had the horse ignore
players commands in some situations to
better emulate the behavior of a real
animal one thing away they never
predicted was the emotional bond players
made with Agra
during their long rides across the
Forbidden Lands he had an idea to take
that bond of a boy and his pet and
explore it in his next game project
Krakow upon completion of Shadow of the
Colossus a waiter contemplated the long
development time of his last two games
and decided to create something good in
a short period of time project Krakow
entered active development in 2007 for
the then one-year-old PlayStation 3 the
game was to follow many similar
narrative threads from ICO and Shadow of
the Colossus a young boy kidnapped and
awakened in a strange unfamiliar castle
comes across a chained up giant Griffon
like creature named Krakow while
resistant to the boy at first trucko
slowly begins to accept his help and
guidance and together the two set out to
escape their prison and find a way home
the core concept of the game was
intended to explore the developing
friendship between Trico and the boy as
they set out on a grand adventure by
2009 the team felt they had completed
enough of the game to allow it to be
showcased at that year's e3 under the
title The Last Guardian behind the
scenes however president of Sony
worldwide studios Shuhei Yoshida felt
development was slow he stated that the
team was struggling to meet a waiter's
vision on the PlayStation 3 hardware and
revealed the trailer released in 2009
was running at a much lower frame rate
and had been sped up in post-production
in 2011 Sony brought in help from its
internal teams to try and help Team Ico
optimize the game for the ps3 without
warning in late November of 2011 Game
Director for Matteo Aida left Sony he
cited the sense of crisis within himself
and upon leaving decided to set up a new
company gen design with several former
team ICO members but the new company was
faced with a choice start something new
or finish what they had started with The
Last Guardian ultimately a waiter opted
to maintain oversight of the project and
work alongside Sony's internal Japan
studio as a contractor as work continued
in 2012 the game's sluggish performance
on the ps3 Hardware was a continuing
cause of concern and with the launch of
the PlayStation 4 only a year away Sony
made the call to shift development to
the more powerful platform following the
switch certainly brought in even more
internal teams including ps4 lead
architect mark Cerny
to help migrate the highly customized
code across to the new platform work
progressed slowly and the Last Guardian
slowly faded from the public eye
in 2011 North American video game
retailer Game Stop cancelled all
pre-orders for the game following a
clerical error then in 2015
Sony allowed The Last Guardian trademark
to lapse in another unfortunate
bookkeeping oversight these events
coupled with the lack of any new info
from Sony outside of the occasional it's
not cancelled or workers progressing
statement led many to believe the title
would never see the light of day at e3
2015 The Last Guardian was reintroduced
at Sony's e3 conference with a confirmed
final it's definitely happening release
date of 2016 even though there wasn't a
live demo reveal on stage due to
treecko's unpredictable AI several
journalists got hands-on time with a
playable build of the game on the show
floor and confirmed it was a tangible
playable for real 100% video game that
was definitely coming out Fumito owada
has confirmed that even with all the
delays change of platforms and shifting
development teams the final game
represents his initial vision for The
Last Guardian we'll have to wait and see
if the story of troika and the boy
resonates with gamers like ICO and
Shadow of the Colossus before it but
from what we've seen so far the Last
Guardian looks like a completely
different and unique experience from any
video game released in the last eight
years
you